[Música]
Donald Trump estará nuevamente en la
carrera por la presidencia de Estados
Unidos el ex mandatario confirmó su
precandidatura desde su residencia de
bar al lago en Florida Trump dijo que el
regreso de Estados Unidos comienza ahora
el presidente Joe biden le respondió
desde Bali aseguró que Trump Le falló a
la Unión Americana
el gobierno de Polonia atribuyó a un
misil de fabricación rusa la explosión
ocurrida en el este del país cerca de la
frontera con Ucrania Varsovia Llama a
consultas al embajador ruso puse una
alerta a sus fuerzas armadas y está
evaluando consultar a sus socios de la
otan si se trata de un ataque a su
territorio
en México un informe de la Comisión
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos
detalla que no Habrá justicia en el caso
de los 43 estudiantes de Ayotzinapa si
las autoridades no tienen Independencia
la institución también manifestó su
preocupación por la demora injustificada
en la aplicación de órdenes de
aprehensión en ese caso ampliamos en
esta emisión
en France 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan la jornadas soy
Valentina Torres Sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos con información
de Estados Unidos porque Donald Trump
vuelve a la carrera por la presidencia
del país el ex mandatario confirmó su
precandidatura de Cara a las elecciones
de 2024 antes del anuncio oficial Trump
entregó los documentos ante la autoridad
electoral para oficializar su aspiración
recordemos que el presidente Joe biden
informó que confirmara su candidatura el
próximo enero escuchemos el anuncio del
ex mandatario
con el fin de hacer que Estados Unidos
sea más grande y más gloriosa de nuevo
ese anunciando hoy mi candidatura a la
presidencia de los Estados Unidos
yo estoy aspirando porque creo que el
mundo no ha visto todavía la gloria
verdadera de lo que esta nación puede
ser no Hemos llegado ese pináculo
creanlo uno
y de hecho podemos ir mucho más allá y
vamos a tener que ir más allá primero
Tenemos que salir de esta trinchera
ustedes no se imagina lo que podemos
lograr
previamente conversamos con Cristóbal
Vázquez corresponsal de France 24 en la
capital estadounidense que nos dio más
detalles de este mensaje de Trump
si abordó problemas esenciales que han
venido siendo una pierna en el zapato
para los presidentes anteriores
incluyéndolo a él como presidente el
tema de la droga el tema del fentanilo y
este y la cantidad de muertes que se
derivan del fentanilo De hecho son
200.000 muertes al año derivados de
drogas sintéticas que él dijo había
empezado a atacar precisamente siendo
mucho más fuerte en la frontera
construyendo el muro no dándole según él
pues espacio a las mafias como si lo
está dando el según el presidente el ex
presidente Donald Trump sí lo está dando
Joe biden abordó el tema de la educación
dijo que será mucho más fuerte en cuanto
a la teoría crítica racial que es una
teoría que aboga para no seguirle
infundando y educando a los niños la
historia sobre el tema de la guerra
civil estadounidense la esclavitud el
maltrato hacia la comunidad
afroamericana habló por ejemplo también
de temas sensibles como es el tema de la
participación de jóvenes transgénero en
deportes femeninos dijo que los hombres
no podían simplemente participar en
deportes femeninos habló también de que
él fue una víctima fue una víctima del
FBI y del Estado profundo se refirió al
tema del Estado profundo en en cuanto a
su allanamiento en la mansión de Mara
lago el cuestionó por ejemplo que por
qué no se le había hecho ese mismo
allanamiento a hillary Clinton a Barack
Obama y a y y a otros y a otras figuras
fuertes de la política la demócrata
cambiamos de tema continuamos en Polonia
porque el gobierno nacional atribuyó a
un misil de fabricación rusa la
explosión registrada en el distrito de
lublin en el este del país muy cerca de
la frontera con Ucrania el estallido
provocó la muerte de dos personas por lo
que Varsovia convocó trabajado ruso
destacado ante el gobierno polaco las
autoridades pusieron en alerta a las
fuerzas armadas y se estudian consultas
a los socios de la otan para determinar
si dicha detonación es considerada como
una amenaza su territorio el presidente
de Polonia Andrés duda dijo que es muy
probable que su país active el artículo
4 de la carta de la otan este miércoles
en una reunión de emergencia
hemos decidido Llamar al embajador de la
federación rusa al Ministerio de
relaciones exteriores el ministro de
relaciones exteriores hablará pronto con
el embajador ruso
nos mantenemos en contacto con el
gobierno de Ucrania el señor presidente
habló con el señor presidente celensky
estoy en contacto con el Primer Ministro
de Ucrania
la inflación en alza y los
inconvenientes económicos que atraviesa
Estados Unidos han generado que los
ciudadanos vean comprometidas su
capacidad para adquirir casas y terrenos
las tasas hipotecarias se elevaron a su
pico máximo desde 2002 duplicando las
cifras registradas en 2021 Ramiro cueva
Barberena nos cuenta más
el llamado sueño americano ha quedado
condicionado por la situación económica
en Estados Unidos la creciente inflación
y el encarecimiento del costo de vida
provocaron que el acceso a un inmueble
sea difícil para los ciudadanos y
generaron una caída en las ventas Bueno
creo que en este punto Estamos buscando
esa corrección en el mercado y está
sucediendo con las tasas de interés
actualmente en 7%. realmente Es un shock
para algunos compradores
sin embargo otros vendedores se
mantienen optimistas Y esperan que la
situación se normalice pronto
sinceramente no estoy de acuerdo ni
justifico este gran miedo no creo que
sea lo que la gente está construyendo
con las opiniones divididas analistas
aseguran que las tasas de interés
bajarán cuando se reduzca la inflación y
mientras tanto ofrecen otras
alternativas
creo que hay un par de soluciones una es
ahorrar un poco más y la otra es comprar
una casa más barata de lo que sería de
otro modo
la combinación de altas tasas de interés
Y todavía mucha incertidumbre sobre la
inflación significa que la gente está
postergando las compras creo que va a
continuar por un tiempo con más del 7%
el mercado inmobiliario estadounidense
afronta la mayor tasa hipotecaria desde
el 2002 y duplica el pico máximo
registrado en 2021 en tanto que según la
asociación de banqueros hipotecarios la
demanda de hipotecas está en su ritmo
más lento desde 1997 integrantes de la
Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos junto relatora especial para
México presentaron un tercer informe del
mecanismo de seguimiento al caso
Ayotzinapa en el que advirtieron que si
las autoridades que investigan el caso
no tienen Independencia no Habrá
justicia recordemos que se trata del
caso de los 43 estudiantes desaparecidos
en el Estado de Guerrero en 2014 los
detalles en el reporte de nuestro
corresponsales Ciudad de México Mario
carbonell
la Comisión Interamericana de Derechos
Humanos presentó el tercer informe del
mecanismo especial de seguimiento al
asunto Ayotzinapa en el documento la
cidh expresa preocupación por algunos
aspectos por ejemplo la demora
injustificada en la aplicación de
órdenes de aprensión y reiteran su
inquietud por la cancelación de 21
órdenes de atención que ya habían sido
libradas también advierten que a pesar
de que existe un contexto político
favorable al más alto nivel en la
alusión a la apertura que hay por parte
del ejecutivo persiste mucha resistencia
para entregar información o archivos que
están en manos de instancias de
seguridad nacional En este sentido
también advierten que la unidad especial
de investigación y litigación del caso
Ayotzinapa ha visto entorpecida su labor
Pues no ha tenido el mismo acceso a la
información que sí tienen por ejemplo la
comisión presidencial para el acceso a
la verdad y el propio hiey
establecen que es necesario profundizar
en la responsabilidad penal por el
delito de desaparición forzada con
especial énfasis en la cadena de Mando
política militar y de instancia de
seguridad civil recomiendan establecer
una política de comunicación que evite
la contradicción en la que han incurrido
las distintas instancias también
Proponen que sea un solo juzgado el que
tenga conocimiento de los distintos
procesos relacionados en el caso
Ayotzinapa las integrantes de la cidh en
conferencia de prensa en la Escuela
Normal Rural Raúl Isidro burdes de
Ayotzinapa refrendaron su compromiso
para acompañar a los a los familiares a
los padres de los estudiantes en la
búsqueda de justicia y acceso a la
verdad establecieron que el caso de la
desaparición de los 43 normalistas no es
aislado que se da en un contexto de
constante violación en los derechos
humanos en Guerrero y en un país en el
que hay más de 100.000 personas
reportadas como desaparecidas y 52
y cuerpos aún no identificados
finalizamos con los nominados a la
edición número 65 de los premios Grammy
que se celebrarán el próximo 5 de
Febrero en la ciudad estadounidense de
Los Ángeles
Beyoncé está nominada 9 categorías y es
la favorita para triunfar en las tres
más importantes mejor canción grabación
y álbum del año entre los nominados
también se encuentra el puertorriqueño
Bad Bunny que por primera vez logró
entrar en las categorías principales con
su disco Un verano sin ti que compite
como mejor álbum del año mejor álbum de
música urbana y mejor interpretación
solista de pop por la canción
Moscú
es todo por el momento en France 24
quédense con nosotros que volvemos en
breve
[Música]